when i met him i was like are you
kidding me zoey deschanel
is gushing over her boyfriend jonathan
scott
the new girl star took to instagram with
these adorable photos of the couple
the bar has been raised so high in the
reflective post
zoe wrote quote my 2020 mvp
was this guy who always made me feel
happy
in spite of a weird and uncertain year
hoping 2021 is full of silver linings
for everyone
jonathan also posted one of the photos
to his instagram
and wrote quote i'm dedicating this year
to love
happiness and the pursuit of helping
others
i feel like i've got a good jump start
on the love part
e.t first reported the stars were dating
back in 2019
they met while filming this episode of
carpool karaoke
[Music]
and if her post wasn't cute enough zoe
recently opened up to e.t
about how their relationship has grown
in the past
year oh he completes me what does that
mean you know we're like a really great
pair i think we're very complimentary
you know and it's nice because
i think we both are people that like to
do things for
each other so it's a really it's just a
really good
relationship and i it's been nice
actually to
be quarantined together um because we
both have our little you know like i
like to cook a lot so i cook a lot of
meals and then he
kind of like likes to fix things so even
on thanksgiving like i was cooking and
he's like had a list of he had a
checklist of
stuff he was gonna do around the house
so so nice he's the he's the nicest
person in the world
earlier in the year the property
brothers star opened up about how fast
they had fallen
for each other i mean i've never been
with somebody who gets along as well
with
the people i care about um who who shows
me
daily that she loves me and and i love
her in return so it's i mean i i love
the fact that if you took me a year ago
i would never have thought i was on this
path with somebody who i'm
madly in love with so it's very exciting
right now we're just
reveling in the fact that we love each
other madly and we're still discovering
each other it's the most
incredible relationship ever so we're
content in that but it's
this is definitely you know something
i've never experienced before in my life